[Music]
here's your money briefing for Monday
March 20th I'm Erin Delmore for the Wall
Street Journal filling in for J.R Whalen
an investment that often doesn't get a
lot of attention is certificates of
deposit but now demand for short-term
CDs is at its highest level since the
2008 financial crisis I'm Erin Delmore
and joining me is Wall Street Journal
reporter hardika Singh hardika thank you
for being with us thank you so much for
having me give us a bit of context here
why are individual investors looking for
alternatives to investing in the stock
market right now well the easy answer to
that is that markets are horrible right
now for investing people are really
really nervous about last year and this
year too even though there has been a
slight rebound it seems like a lot of
investors don't trust it from late last
year we started seeing investors just
rush into cash as an asset class and it
seems like this year too that trend is
continuing people don't have many places
to go where they can hide out from this
Market volatility so what makes these
Investments like CDs money market funds
high yield savings accounts and treasury
bills so attractive right now these
Investments are usually considered to be
cash Investments or as safe as cash the
reason why is that you can go inside
money market funds and they contain
mostly U.S government bonds which are
Ultra safe so you are buying a money
market fund which buys those government
bonds so you're essentially in a way
investing your money into something that
is considered to be nearly as safe as
cash which is pretty good if you go
inside CDs most of your money is insured
by the FDIC so up to 250k the government
will step in and essentially make sure
that you have access to your funds so a
lot of these different Investments such
as money market funds treasury bills
high yield savings account certificates
of deposits or CDs they're all boasting
really high rates right now that's
something they haven't done in a really
really long time and obviously in a
market where stocks continue to go down
bonds continue to fall that's going to
be very attractive if you can get five
percent by holding a CD why would you go
into stocks well how is this different
from what we've seen over the past
decade over the past decade the Federal
Reserve kept interest rates very very
low and obviously that was to help the
economy after the 2008 financial crisis
that started an absolute spectacular
bull run into the stock market where we
saw tech stocks rallying crazy they
drove dozens of highs for the major
indexes and no one really looked at Cash
during that time because it was the era
of Tina or as we call it there's no
alternative to stocks if you wanted to
make money you had to go into stocks
there was no way you were going to make
money by holding cash in fact there's a
statistic that says that if you held
cash from the end of 1999 to let's say
today you would have lost over 300
percent in gains if that money had been
invested in stocks well that's the track
record that the stock market outperforms
holding on to cash so are the investors
you spoke to using this as a long-term
investment strategy or as a short-term
Safe Harbor
It's tricky to answer that some retail
investors I spoke with they are planning
to hide out in cash right now and then
the stock market gets a little bit more
beaten down they're hoping to deploy
some of that cash and use it to buy the
dip so one investor I spoke with Andrew
hippel he's trying to do that he is in
cash right now in a stable value fund he
also has a high yield savings account
and when stocks decline a bit more he
said he plans to add to his stock
allocation
so he's just using this to hide out from
the market volatility another investor I
spoke with he's been in cash forever
like not completely but he holds way
more cash Holdings than what would be
considered in a normal portfolio by
analyst investors he said that since
he's lived through the.com bubble the
2008 financial crisis the 2020 Market
Panic he's planning to continue holding
cash so hardika what else should someone
who doesn't trade for a living know
before they go ahead and take these same
steps so a lot of the financial managers
and investors I spoke with said
essentially that if you flock to cash
during Market turbulence you risk
missing out on future gains because you
basically sold pretty low and now you're
going to buy high in the future so
younger investors especially aren't
advised to do this because they risk
missing out on a bigger rebound or
something however investors who are
approaching retirement government they
are recommended to rotate Into Cash a
little bit more because in that case you
don't have as much time to recover from
losses most of your gains have already
been made they're already posted there
so if you lose your money now you don't
have time to make it up hardika you are
our eyes and ears on the ground or in
this case on the web on Tick Tock and
Discord is this the hot tip of the
moment it most certainly is it's hard to
scroll to finance Tick Tock or fintok
without coming across somebody saying
hey have we opened a high yield savings
account yet are you locking in this like
CD rate at five percent if not you're
missing out on money like high yield
savings accounts are so popular right
now in fact one of the individual
investors I spoke with he said that's
where he discovered what a high yield
savings account is and how cash and cash
like funds are providing such high
yields which is pretty interesting well
I was just going to say isn't that a bit
of a reversal we all remember when that
cohort these groups of individual
investors organizing on social media
flocked to meme stocks cryptocurrencies
and really moved markets over it so now
that you're seeing them taking the
conservative route going to cash is that
surprising it is surprising but not as
much if you considered that this is one
of the few places where you can make
money right now yeah retail investors
were banding together on Discord making
all these types of servers saying we're
going to take Dogecoin or something to
the moon and obviously it has completely
changed everybody is talking right now
about cash this is at the top of
investor spine and that's your money
briefing I'm Erin Delmore for the Wall
Street Journal
foreign
[Music]